research the gentleman from missouri is
recognized
thank you mr speaker i would like to
remind uh the body
that the reason why we're here today is
because the reckless behavior
all these cuts on medicare all of these
cuts
are because the house democrats forced
through
a nearly two trillion dollar spending
bill and the reason
why we have the paygo statutory
provision
is because president obama signed it
into law
and the house democrats passed it so the
cuts
are the result today of all the policies
that democrats have been doing since
2010.
i would love to yield three minutes to
the gentleman from georgia
gentlemen is recognized for three
minutes gentleman from georgia
thank you mr speaker mr speaker today
we're addressing a problem that didn't
even exist a week ago
it did not even exist last week
republicans stood on this floor and we
argued against the 1.9 trillion dollar
partisan package last week
there were many reasons to oppose it but
one of the most significant
reasons was the fact that the bill would
trigger cuts to medicare
and other essential programs we argued
that it would harm all of our
constituents i argued that it would harm
my constituents in georgia to my friend
my
my fellow delegation member
this bill penalized the state of georgia
more than
any state in the united states more than
any state in the nation
georgia was punished we lost 1.3 billion
dollars because of the funding formula
because we didn't shut down our state we
didn't destroy our economy
and the funding was based on the
unemployment rate and not population
and where did the rates went to blue
states and what did it do to medicare in
the state of georgia
we lost 11 and a half billion
dollars that would have went to the
seniors on medicare
in the state of georgia and where did it
go
again it went to california went to new
york
it went to the blue states it went to
the states that
shut down their businesses and destroyed
their economies
yet the bill was pushed forward anyway
this could have all been avoided
altogether
we could have crafted a bipartisan
package that would not have triggered
these medicare cuts instead those across
the aisle resorted to forcing the bill
through reconciliation
and in the end they passed a package
filled with political favors on the back
of our seniors
again this could have been avoided but
today we need to fix this for our
constituents by recognizing we have a
spending problem
now that the largest stimulus bill in
our history has been signed into law our
deficit for the year will also break
records
we are now projected to have a federal
deficit of 3.4 trillion dollars
and debt as a share of our gdp will be
over 100
for only the second time in our
country's history
my colleagues have shown little regard
for actually paying for this reckless
spending for political favor
that is why i urge my colleagues to find
a way to pay for restoring the cuts to
medicare
and the first place i suggest looking
for it
is in an over 90 percent of the last
package that will not
go to addressing the pandemic
mr speaker mr speaker
this is wrong my colleagues know it's
wrong
let's get this fixed thank you and i
yield back
gentlemen yells back gentlemen from
missouri research the gentleman from
kentucky's recognized mr speaker i'm
uh pleased to yield two minutes to the
gentleman from california a
distinguished member
of the ways and means committee mr
panetta gentleman from california is
recognized for two minutes thank you mr
speaker mr chairman
today i rise in support of h.r 1868 to
prevent these harmful budget cuts
to vital agricultural programs that are
relied on by farmers
farm workers and food insecure families
in
all of our districts if we don't pass
this bill today
29 billion dollars in agricultural
funding would be
subject to these sequester cuts those
types of cuts
would zero out funding for such crucial
agricultural programs
like eqip and the conservation
stewardship program and the regional
conservation
partnership program see in my district
on the central coast
mid central coast of california many
farmers ranchers and forest land owners
rely on those types of helpful programs
not just to survive mr speaker but to
succeed
they use those programs to harvest their
products and to be part of the climate
solution
see the producers in my district
understand and appreciate the old adage
which called
hoosafrock which basically says the land
they use
now must be kept fresh and fertile not
just for them
but for future generations and it's
these programs that contribute to their
current product
and yes that type of forward thinking
sequester cuts would also prevent the
federal government from purchasing and
donating food to food banks
through section 32 purchases after the
year we had
in which food banks contributed so much
to the food and security
of so many of my constituents we should
be doing
everything we can to protect and bolster
our food programs
we should also also be doing everything
we can to protect the production of food
but sequestration cuts would compromise
parts many parts of the farm bill like
the specialty crop block
grants or the agricultural research
extension programs at public
universities as the co-chair of the
congressional ag research caucus
i know that these types of ag research
programs help our farmers meet the
challenges of 2021
and will allow them to prepare for
challenges of the 21st
century mr speaker as a representative
from the salad bowl of the world it's my
job to ensure that my farmers and farm
workers and food insecure families
have all the tools that they need to
live and lead healthy and productive
lives
as representatives of congress in this
nation
thank you mr recognized 30 seconds as
representative
in congress for this nation it's all of
our jobs to ensure that the programs for
those tools
and that food are here not just today
but for tomorrow
we can live up to that responsibility by
supporting h.r
1868 thank you mr speaker i yield that
gentleman yells back gentlemen from
kentucky research gentlemen from
missouri is recognized
thank you mr speaker i yield two minutes
to the newest member of the budget
committee the gentleman from mississippi
gentlemen from mississippi is recognized
for two minutes
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i rise
in opposition
to h.r 1868 the bill to prevent
across-the-board direct spending
cuts it should come as no surprise to my
democrat friends
you were told during the what little
process we had of the 1.9 billion
trillion dollar spending bill that it
was going to be disproportionately hurt
seniors
that it was going to hurt farmers you
were told this and you ignored that
and knowing that you would have to fix
it later and drive something
it just is irresponsibly through now
it disproportionately share of this goes
this two trillion dollars goes to
urban poorly run democratic cities and
state
at the expense of our rural blue-collar
americans who
feed clothe and protect america every
day
we told you this weeks ago and you
ignored it
i am deeply concerned that the democrats
would enact a bill that adds 1.9
trillion dollars to an american deficit
without the support of a single
republican
over 200 voting members of this body had
no
opportunity for input into this
massively destructive package
the biden administrator promised the
american people bipartisanship and unity
however they unilaterally drafted and
pushed this bill
through without any republican support
now the democrats have hastily put
together
a bill that jeopardizes the standing of
our seniors and mortgages the future of
our children
my colleague ranking member smith
reminded the democrats the consequences
of such a dramatic increase
in mandatory spending a 36 billion
cut to medicare beginning in 2022.
democrats would rather cut benefits to
american seniors in rural america
than give up checks to illegal
immigrants and prisoners
the democrats have taken advantage of
the need of the american people
my colleagues and i are advocating for a
more responsible alternative that will
remove the wasteful spending of the
violent bailout bill
and protect our most vulnerable
population we must cut the billions of
liberal state bailouts and ensure the
money already authorizes spirit
responsible
thank you mr speaker i yield back
gentlemen yours back uh
gentleman from missouri research
gentleman from kentucky is recognized
mr speaker i just want to remind the
gentleman from mississippi along with
all the other
members of this body that his citizens
will receive in total 900 million
dollars from just the 1400 dollar checks
that's the average that every
congressional district
is going to receive and i hope that at
some point they will realize the
benefits of that injection of capital
into economy an economy that's
struggling
and now i'm pleased to yield two minutes
to the gentleman from connecticut a
distinguished member of the education
and labor committee mr courtney
government from connecticut is
recognized for two minutes thank you mr
speaker and i want to thank the chairman
of the budget committee for
him and his committee staff steady hand
over the last couple of months to make
sure that the american rescue plan
was enacted last week mr speaker in that
week's time
since today up to today the american
people have had a chance to listen to
the debate
and evaluate for themselves what they
think of the american rescue plan a
morning consult poll that came out
yesterday showed 72 percent support
for the plan 44 among republicans
across the country and why not 90
million americans
on wednesday received 1400
checks totaling 242 billion and for
those americans who are not connected
digitally to the irs
they are going to get their checks
through the mail for those americans who
are following their 2020 tax returns
whose income now qualifies them for the
economic impact payments they're going
to receive their check
on monday people who are on unemployment
got an extension because of the american
rescue plan these are working people
in the service sectors in the commercial
real estate sector
in those parts of the of the economy
that are still
hurting out there and every no vote was
was a no vote in terms of people getting
that critical economic help
another vote of confidence happened on
wednesday which is the federal reserve
board met
and and they voted to keep their key
benchmark rate
at zero not just for a couple of weeks
or a couple of months but for the
balance of 2021
for all of 2022 and into 2023 so for all
the hysterical
arguments that were overheating the
economy and inflation is going to go up
jerome powell donald trump's nominee
as chair of the federal reserve who took
questions for over an
hour on this inflation issue
argued accurately with the battalion of
economists
that they have at the federal reserve
that there is still slack in this
economy
and 10 million folks on unemployment
need to get this type of fiscal relief
that the american
rescue plan responsibly targeted
is going to make sure that this com this
country recovers as soon as possible
this is a routine bill today we've done
it over and over again
over in the last 10 years vote yes and
make sure that this economy
as the chairman of the federal reserve
advised us
gets the help it needs i yield that
gentleman years back gentlemen from
kentucky reserves
the gentleman from the series recognized
thank you mr speaker i'd like to yield
three minutes to one of the leading
doctors of the republican conference and
a great member of the budget committee
the gentleman from texas gentleman from
texas is recognized for three minutes
and i thank the gentleman for yielding
um i
am going to speak in opposition to 1868.
but i also feel obligated to point out
that you may say that the inflation rate
is zero but if you bought a gallon of
gas
purchased a two by four at home depot or
bought a sack of quick credit lows
you know that inflation is a real
phenomenon
but i do rise in opposition to 1868
there was no effort made on the part of
the majority party to work with
republicans
on what should be a bipartisan priority
and that is
provider relief i've heard from
physicians i've heard from hospitals in
texas who've struggled financially
throughout the pandemic but the bill we
have before us today
is simply an excuse to wipe out the
scorecard
of the fiscal impact of the 1.9 trillion
dollar
partisan package passed last week and
last week
republicans warned that this would
threaten cuts to medicare
but those warnings were repeatedly
ignored
so look if the house majority really
cared if house democrats really cared
about meaningful health care provider
relief
they would have worked to gain
republican support work with us to build
the bill from the ground up instead
this bill is coming forth toward us as a
hail mary pass right before the medicare
sequester cuts go into effect
in april as a physician i have deep
empathy for those whose medical
practices have been impacted and are now
struggling to stay open i know i've
helped many doctors
many clinics
navigate the provider relief fund over
this past year
we need targeted relief for the
providers that are hurting
and some are hurting more than others so
i am a co-sponsor of hr
1999 which is an alternative approach
that adds
over 12 billion dollars to the provider
relief fund
and ensures that dollars would flow
to those doctors who've experienced lost
revenue or increased cost
this type of financial relief has
already been proven
successful we passed the cares act on
the 27th of march
last year we know it's successful
additionally this alternative bill
ensures that the four percent cut to
medicare providers
that was included in last week's
reconciliation bill
as a result of statuary statute or
statutory pay go
does not go into effect in 2022
the american rescue plan act gifted 350
billion dollars to state and local
governments
that simply was not justified providers
are our state and local communities are
worthy
of funding and it should they should
specifically benefit
from those state and local dollars that
are not necessary
to go where they're planned to go that's
why we would like to redirect the state
and local funding towards provider
relief
maintaining a strong health care
workforce is critical to the health of
this nation
during normal times and is especially
critical during
a public health emergency we should work
together on the right policy solution
to deliver this relief to ensure that it
stands a chance
of actually passing in the other body
and that should be a starting point for
those discussions
and i hope we can come to such a
sensible solution i yield back to the
gentleman from missouri yields back
gentlemen from missouri research
gentlemen from kentucky is recognized
mr speaker i'm happy to yield two
minutes to the gentlewoman from illinois
a distinguished member
of the budget committee miss chikauki
general was recognized for two minutes
thank you mr chairman
i am proud to co-sponsor hr 1868
to prevent arbitrary cuts to medicare
and to ensure that the american rescue
uh plan is treated in the same way
as previous coronavirus
bills have been have been treated
including the
the cares act this legislation as we all
know is needed this fix is needed to
avoid painful cuts
to our mandatory spending programs and
let's remember
the hypocrisy is overwhelming here that
the democrats voted with republicans
in 2017 to avoid medicare cuts as a
result
of the republicans tax scam a two
trillion dollar bill
the tax cut that went mostly to the
wealthy
our hard our health care workers have
been working
non-stop for over a year fighting this
pandemic
they do not deserve a cut in medicare
payments
for taking care of seniors and people
with disabilities
by removing the uh sequester
we can ensure that providers keep
their their doors open and they can
continue to treat the
uh the their patients though republicans
voted against
the american rescue plan which they
shouldn't have
i sincerely hope that today they will
join us
and vote to protect these programs
that enjoy broad bipartisan public
support
and ensure that our our commitment
to our nation seniors and people with
disabilities
are met during this public health crisis
especially now we need to be working
together
as we did for you when you were giving
tax cuts to the wealthiest americans
we were not going to let medicare suffer
and i yield back
general neos back gentlemen from
kentucky research the gentleman from
missouri is recognized
thank you mr speaker i'd like to remind
the lady from illinois
that actions speak louder than words and
that she
did not help the folks in 2017
that she tried to point out the
hypocrisy i'd like to
uh yield three minutes to the gentleman
from texas
gentleman from texas is recognized for
three minutes i i think the chairman
and mr speaker to the ladies point about
working together
democrats did not offer uh any uh
hand of bipartisanship uh in this
ram and jam job on the 2 trillion
bailout bill
they even lost democrats on it and so
they didn't work with us
um it was a pure partisan play uh and
there's a reason for that
it it's mostly unrelated to covet
it is bailout galore it is a
wish list of of of the liberals
in this house and they just pushed it
through
and and called it in disguise coveted
relief
but the fundamental principle we're
talking about today is pago this is a
law
passed by democrats signed by a
democratic president that says
fundamentally and american people
understand this if you spend beyond your
means
you got to find a way to pay for it
gotta offset it
or you go into debt the american people
they don't pay their bills
mr speaker they get their water turned
off or their electricity turned off the
irs will hunt them down
put them in jail if they don't pay their
taxes
they'll have their mortgage foreclosed
their cars repossessed
that's what happens to the american
people when they don't pay their bills
president obama when he signed the law
said you can't spend a dollar
unless you cut a dollar elsewhere i
agree with him
miss pelosi our speaker gave a speech
and she gave glowing uh points
as she embraced uh wholeheartedly uh
and full-throatedly this pay go she said
it's important our fiscal soundness to
our children and grandchildren
she said who could oppose this great
idea she went on to say this
investment in our children's future must
be paid for or
else we're heaping a debt onto our
children
30 trillion almost and counting 30
trillion
who's going to pay for that not us
not you not us our kids are going to pay
for it
these are miss pelosi's words mr speaker
this pay-as-you-go is part of a
blueprint for fiscal responsibility
subjecting spending to the harshest
scrutiny every federal dollar
that is spent must be subject to
scrutiny to make sure taxpayers get
their money's worth
bailing out union pensions giving city
and states money
who horribly mismanaged their business
prior to covet
giving people more money to be on
unemployment than they made in their
previous job
paying people who were not economically
harmed in this coveted disaster
all of these things there is a litany of
wasteful
irresponsible and unnecessary spending
hundreds of billions of dollars
and she says every dollar is going to be
scrutinized or we're going to stick it
to our seniors
we're going to stick it to our kids
that's
that's a profile in courage if i ever
saw one now that's the leadership that
made this country great mr
speaker these are miss pelosi's words
not mine but i agree with her
we have an opportunity here
to do the right thing by our children to
offset the spending here in this 2
trillion bailout
with the wasteful spending that's in
there and i gave you a list mr speaker
i plead with you and i plead with my
colleagues offset this and do right by
our
kids and their future in this country
and i yield back
the gentleman from missouri research the
gentleman from kentucky
is recognized mr speaker may i inquire
as to how much time remains on both
sides
from kentucky has 11 and a half minutes
a gentleman from missouri has
one and a quarter minute remaining thank
you mr speaker mr speaker i'm now happy
to yield two minutes to the gentlewoman
from texas
a distinguished member of the budget
committee ms jackson lee
general from texas is recognized for two
minutes i thank god to sing as chairman
whenever you hear the words of speaker
pelosi
you know that she is leading leading us
on the fight to protect our seniors
i'm glad to co-sponsor this legislation
to be a strong supporter
of being on the front seat of protecting
our seniors whenever you hear
uh us being demagogue from those on the
other side using demagoguery
you can be assured that when they pass
the tax bill
it was not having seniors as their
priority
but when you hear the word medicare you
know that democrats are standing strong
to make sure that not one dime is taken
away from our seniors
with medicare open letter to my seniors
in my district
open message to my seniors we will die
on the spine to protect your
medicare that is what we're doing today
on the floor of the house
not one dime will come out of your
medicare
i am proud to support h.r 1868
which excludes the budgetary effects of
the american rescue plan
of 2021 from scorecards established by
the statutory
pay-as-you-go or paygo act of 2010
preventing across-the-board cuts to
numerous direct spending programs
that's what we're doing here today we
are taking our seniors seriously
seniors have no fear with all of this
demagoguery
because we are going to make sure that
not one dime
comes out of your pocket in addition
seniors
you're going to be living in cities like
houston where
it says that houston's share of the
stimulus package is 600 million dollars
that is going to help keep your city
services going
your fire your police your trash pickup
seniors
we know you call my office these are
important to you
let me also indicate that your health
care will be in good place
with this particular program your
grandchildren will be able to go back to
school with
almost a billion dollars to the houston
independent school district
stimulus checks you're not going to be
ignored seniors you're going to be able
to get stimulus checks
directly into your accounts your
grandchildren
your children will be able to get for
them thirty six hundred dollars for a
five-year-old
three thousand dollars
gentlemen uh has an additional 30
seconds
i thank the gentleman three thousand
dollars for children above nine years
old
you'll be able to have uh on enhanced
unemployment for the young people in
your life
uh that have been unemployed and then of
course you may
have the ability to have that local
restaurant and i fought for this
local restaurant to be open again with
28 billion dollars
the issue of public assistance or
local government assistance was
something i was allowed to offer a
motion to instruct
it was something that i thought that we
could not abandon but we will not
abandon you as seniors
we will not let them touch one dime of
medicare
as our friends on the other side have
vote for this legislation
because we are seniors first i asked
unanimous consent to place into the
record
the houston article dated march 10 2021
600 million dollars for the city of
houston without objection time has
expired gentlemen from the missouri
reserves
from kentucky gentlemen from missouri is
recognized a reserve
general reserves gentleman from kentucky
is recognized mr speaker i'm happy to
yield two minutes to the gentleman from
texas a distinguished member of the
budget committee mr doggett
chairman for texas is recognized for two
minutes
55 years ago president lyndon b johnson
overcame sustained republican opposition
to enact medicare
it's been a literal lifeline for
millions
those who suffered without health care
before medicare
now have access to a family physician
and hospital care when they need it
former republican speaker newt gingrich
in this very room
plotted to let medicare wither on the
vine
millions of americans would have
withered had he been successful
yet generations of republicans have
sought to privatize it
cut it weaken it and surely some of the
strongest evidence
of the success of medicare through all
of these times
is the claim by today's republicans that
after
so many failed attempts to weaken
medicare they are here
quite amazingly claiming to be its new
protectors
of course this comes following their
understandable desperation
to justify their inexplicable efforts
to deny the relief that was offered by
the american rescue plan
the survivor benefits the unemployment
small business rental assistance so
vitally needed
the support for getting our students
back in school the funding to keep state
and local
employees doing their jobs
these republicans have resisted that
rescue plan
with the same fervor that they resisted
medicare in the first place
so determined were these folks to oppose
anything that president biden advances
that they claim
that they've come out here and they've
claimed that the rescue plan
means medicare cuts which certainly it
does not
most medicare falls with the
jurisdiction
of the ways and means health
subcommittee that i chair
we do need to strengthen medicare the
latest financial report
suggests that additional revenues will
be needed to sustain medicare
beginning in 2026 some of the changes
that are needed are largely accounting
adjustments
and others will require additional
revenue they have additional 30 seconds
i yield the gentleman an additional 30
seconds
gentleman has an additional 30 seconds
what our colleagues should be doing is
coming
together to work with us to ensure the
permanent security
of medicare medicare works but after 55
years
it needs some updates it's not provided
adequate protection against
pharmaceutical price gouging
it does not cover most of dental hearing
and vision care and of course too many
americans
they're just too young to be in medicare
i believe we need to be working together
to make medicare better and more widely
available
to more americans because health
security is american security and i
yield back
yells back a gentleman from kentucky
research gentleman from missouri is
recognized i reserve
gentlemen gentleman reserves gentlemen
from kentucky is recognized mr speaker
i'm happy to yield two minutes to the
gentlewoman from illinois a
distinguished member of the agriculture
and appropriations committee's miss
bustos
gentlewoman is recognized for two
minutes thank you chairman yarmouth and
thank you mr speaker
i rise today to support hr 1868 i know
we've talked this morning about the
importance of that bill protecting
medicare i want to talk with you for
a couple minutes here about its
protection of
farm supports and other direct spending
as it pertains to our family farmers
as chair of the agriculture subcommittee
on general farm commodities and risk
management
this bill will protect critical
resources like the commodity credit
corporation
resources that our family farmers depend
on now
more than ever there are nearly 2
million farmers across our nation in the
district that i serve
we have close to 10 000 family farms
but throughout our nation there is no
farm that
isn't touched by the commodity credit
corporation
not one american farmer who wouldn't be
impacted by these cuts in the district i
serve
those close to ten thousand family farm
family farm farmers who wouldn't have
more resources if this were to happen
and who would face challenges as they
try to pay their bills
and put food on the table the truth is
our family farmers have seen an
onslaught of challenges for years each
year worse than the one before it
extreme weather conditions devastated
crops
unstable and uncertain trade markets
that held back exports and economic
growth
and throughout the past year a global
pandemic
that has left many of our farmers
ravaged even as they kept fighting
for fellow americans to keep them fed
coveted 19 has impacted all of us
but thankfully we have never truly seen
empty
store shelves we have our american
farmers to thank for that we have our
american farmers to thank
for the stable food supply and for this
for the certainty
that even after years of challenges even
at the height of this worldwide crisis
our american farmers
have had our backs now it's time for us
to have theirs
a vote against this bill is a vote to
cut
farm funding i urge my colleagues to
vote
to protect our family farmers and vote
yes on this critical bill thank you very
much i yield back
general mormonio's back a gentleman from
kentucky research speaker
i have no other speakers if the ranking
member
has no other speakers i'm prepared to
close prepare to close
gentlemen from kentucky research the
gentleman from missouri is recognized
thank you mr speaker my colleagues and i
have introduced an alternative
a more responsible approach that
protects our seniors and rolls back some
of the more wasteful
and absurd parts of the democratic
bailout bill i would encourage my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle
to put america's seniors ahead of their
special interest allies
join us in finding a solution that
protects and respects america's seniors
and the working class we will offer such
a solution as a motion to recommit
if adopted it will instruct the
committee on the budget to consider an
amendment
to make the sensible cuts in waste
offered in h.r
1999 the protect seniors and cut waste
act mr speaker
i asked unanimous consent to insert the
text of the amendment and the record
immediately prior to the vote on the
motion to recommit without objection
let's put the health care of our seniors
ahead of prisoners
illegal immigrants and the political
class thank you mr speaker
gentleman yields back the balance of his
time the gentleman from kentucky
is recognized mr speaker i
yield myself the remainder of my time
gentleman's recognized
thank you mr speaker the last couple of
months have been
an incredibly uh busy time and the work
that was done
on the american rescue plan from start
to finish was extraordinary
and we owe our staffs an enormous
debt of gratitude at not just the budget
committee staff but the staff of the
12 committees that also contributed to
the drafting of the american rescue plan
and i'd like to take this time to read
the names of the budget committee staff
who
pulled all-nighters all weekenders and
went way beyond the call of duty and
doing the work
on the american rescue plan erica appel
ellen bayless
samantha carter edward etzkorn jose
guillen
jocelyn harris emily king sarah lee
sheila mcdowell diana meredith
layla mojan kimberly overbeek
barbara pike katie raymond scott russell
laura santos raquel spencer
greg waring alexandra weinroth christy
wentworth jennifer wheelock
sam weiss ted zeggers and grady stevens
i want to thank all of them personally
for their work and on behalf of
uh the house in closing mr speaker
i just want to say this you know we
we have heard a lot of
newly found concern about the the
deficit and the debt today
we heard it during the debates this is
the same
party that drove up the deficit three
years ago four years ago now
with a two trillion dollar tax cut
most of which benefited the wealthiest
americans
and according to virtually everyone
who's looked at it didn't even come
close to paying for itself
what we have done in the american rescue
plan
is give an incredible boost
to the american people and the american
people who need the boost most
not one dollar in the american rescue
plan goes to the top one percent of
americans
the vast majority goes to middle and
lower income people struggling to get by
and i i'm kind of amused
when people talk about their states
being cheated uh
the gentleman from georgia talked about
how georgia was cheated
under this american rescue plan
georgia gets over eight billion dollars
twice as much
as georgia got under the cares act that
doesn't even count
all of the money that's going to the
georgia citizens and as i said
in every congressional district in this
country on average
the people the citizens we represent
will get 900 million
dollars every congressional district and
my friend
from missouri he talked about his family
of four and i know his math is better
than this
but a family of four doesn't get
fourteen hundred dollars as he mentioned
family four gets fourteen hundred times
four
which is fifty six hundred dollars and
then two children depending on their
ages get
at least three thousand dollars each so
that family of four
is going to get 11 000 out of this bill
and
to talk about future generations i love
that
um you know i'm sure that when the
national debt
reached a billion dollars under abraham
lincoln there were people saying
wow we're laying a credible burden on
our grandchildren
and when it reached a trillion dollars
under ronald reagan i'm sure there were
people
saying the same thing and when it gets
to 50 trillion
as it probably will next couple of
decades
people will be saying the same thing
we've been accumulating debt for our
entire history
and yet no one has ever been asked to
pay for that debt
and no one ever will so
all in all we're very proud of the
american rescue plan
the american people love the american
rescue plan and this fix which we ask
for today
is something that again is just what the
republicans asked to do
in 2017 it's a routine measure
nobody wants to cut to cut medicare to
providers and certainly benefits to our
citizens
so i'm sure we'll have an actual
bipartisan vote on this today
and i urge all of my colleagues to
support hr 1868
with that i yield back the balance of my
time gentlemen yields back pursuant to
house resolution 232
333 the previous question is order on
the bill
the question is on the engrossment and
the third reading of the bill
those in favor say aye those opposed say
no
the eyes have it third reading a bill to
prevent across the board direct spending
cuts and for other
purposes
for what purpose does the gentleman from
missouri seek recognition
thank you mr speaker i have a motion to
recommit at the desk
the clerk will report the motion mr
smith of missouri moves to recommit the
bill
h.r 1868 to the committee on the budget
pursuant of clause 2b of rule 19 the
previous question is order on the motion
recommit
the question is on the motion those in
favor say aye those opposed say no
the notes have it the motions are not
agreed to mr gentleman from missouri
i request the yeas and nays
pursuant to section 3s of house
resolution 8 the yesterdays are ordered
members will record their votes by
electronic device
so
so
thank you
so
this
right
foreign
foreign
is
purpose does the gentleman from new york
seek recognition the member designated
by congressman brendan boyle pursuant to
hres 8 i inform the house that
congressman boyle
will vote no on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from indiana seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
buchan of indiana pursuant to hres eight
i informed the house that
mr buchanan will vote yay on the motion
to recommit
for what purpose does this chairman from
arizona seek recognition as the member
designated by mrs kirkpatrick pursuant
to
hres eight i informed the house that mr
patrick will vote
no on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from illinois seek recognition
as the member designated by mr rush
pursuant to hps 8 i informed the house
that mr russell vote no on the motion to
recommit
mr
super
this is
is
okay
foreign
easy
oh
foreign
for what purpose does the uh general
women from illinois seek recognition
as the member designated by mr moulton
pursuant to his eight i informed the
house that mr moulton will vote
no on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentleman from
connecticut seek recognition thank you
mr speaker mr speaker is the member
designated by mr adam smith of
washington state pursuant to hres 8.
i informed the house that mr smith will
vote no on the motion to recommit
is
[Music]
hello
oh yeah
okay
for what purpose does the uh gentleman
from california seek recognition
mr speaker is member designated by
congress member vargas
pursuant to house resolution aid i
informed the house
that congress member of argus will vote
no on the motion to recommit
and mr speaker pursu as member
designated by congress member napolitano
pursuant to house resolution eight
i informed the house that congress
member napolitano will also vote no
on the motion to recommit
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
you hear me
yes
a gentleman from california seek
recognition as the member designated by
mr carnos pursuant to hres eight i
inform the house that mr carnos
will vote i will vote no on the motion
to recommit
for what purpose does gentleman from
pennsylvania seek recognition
because the house is designated by mr
lawson in florida pursued the house
resolution eight i informed the house
that mr lawson
will vote nay on motion reconsideration
uh
uh
for what purpose does the gentleman from
north carolina seek recognition
as the member designated by mr bishop of
georgia
pursuant to hres 8 i informed the house
that mr bishop will vote
no he will vote no on the motion to
recommit
as the member designated by mr hastings
of florida
pursuant to hres 8 i informed the house
that mr hastings will vote
no he will vote no on the motion to
recommit
where is he from
for what purpose does the gentleman from
pennsylvania seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by
representative kathy mcmorris rogers
pursuant to house resolution eight
i informed the house that representative
rogers will vote
yes on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from connecticut seek recognition
as the member designated by miss wilson
pursuant to hres 8
i informed the house that miss wilson
will vote no on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
mr bera pursuant to house resolution
eight
i inform the house that mr barrow will
vote no on the motion to recommit
figures the member designated by mr
schneider pursuant to house resolution
eight i informed the house that mr
schneider
will vote motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentleman from
illinois seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr grijalva pursuant to h
res 8. i hereby inform the house that mr
grijalva will vote
no on the motion to recommit
i know
seems like the intensity
for what purpose does the gentleman from
tennessee seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr desjarlais of tennessee
pursuant to h res i inform the house
that mr desjarlais
will vote yey on the motion to recommit
thank you
so
okay
um
for what purpose does the gentleman from
florida seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr
gates pursuant to house res eight
i informed the house that mr gates will
vote yay on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentleman from
indiana seek recognition
as the member designated by mr kaheli
pursuant
h resolution 8 i informed the house that
mr kahele will vote no
on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does gentleman from
florida seek recognition
thank you mr speaker as the member
designated by mr timmons of south
carolina pursuant to hres 8 i informed
the house that mr timmins will vote yes
on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from california seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
desanie
pursuant to hres 8 i informed the house
that mr desanie will vote no
on the motion to recommit
okay
what purpose does the gentleman from
florida seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
miss wasserman schultz
pursuant to a tres eight i informed the
house that miss washman schultz will
vote no on the motion to recommit
from virginia seek recognition mr
speaker as the member designated by mr
mckeach and pursuant to hrs-8 i inform
the house that mr mckeecham will vote no
on the motion recommit and as the member
designated by ms porter pursuant to hrs8
i inform the house and ms porter will
vote no on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentleman from
michigan seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr peters of california pursuant to hres
8
i informed the house that mr peters will
vote no on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentleman from
florida seek recognition
thank you mr speaker as the member
designated by mr buchanan of florida
pursuant to house resolution number
eight i informed the house that mr
buchanan will vote yes
on the motion to recommit thank you
for what purpose does the gentleman from
massachusetts seek recognition
good morning mr speaker as the member
designated by the honorable mr james
langevin of rhode island
and pursuant to house resolution number
eight i'd like to inform the house that
mr langevin will vote no on the motion
to recommit h.r 1868
to prevent across the board direct
spending cuts and for other purposes
thank you
so
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from michigan seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms axne pursuant to hres eight
i informed the house that ms axne will
vote no on the motion to recommit
and as the member designated by ms
slotkin pursuant to hres eight
i informed the house that ms slotkin
will vote no on the motion to recommit
she always
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from massachusetts seek recognition
as the member designated by ms mang
pursuant to hres 8 i informed the house
that ms
bang will vote no on the motion to
recommit
as the member designated by ms bush
pursuant to hrz
i inform the house that ms bush will
vote no on the motion to recommit
as the member designated by ms bordeaux
pursuant to h hres 8 i informed the
house that ms bordeaux will vote no
on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does this gentleman
from virginia seek recognition mr
speaker as the member designated by mr
lowenthal pursuant to hrs8
and foreign motion recommit
as the member designated by mr liu
pursuant to his aide i informed the
estimate
will vote no on the motion to recommit
as a member designated by ms baragon
pursuant to hrs8
and foreign will vote no on the motion
to recommit
as a member designated right mr
blumenthal pursuant to his eight i
important that's mr blumenthal will vote
no
on the motion to recommit as the member
designated by ms
moore pursuant to change eight i
informed the house no on the motion to
recommit
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from cancer seek recognition
uh mr speaker is the member designated
by mr allred pursuant to hsa to inform
the house that mr allred will vote no on
the motionary
commit as the member designated by mr
cleaver pursuant to hres 8 i informed
the house that mr cleaver will vote no
on the motion to recommit
as the member designated by mr kim
pursuant to his 8 i informed the house
that mr kim will vote no on the motion
to recommit
for what purpose does the general woman
from california seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms williams pursuant to hrs8 i informed
the house that miss williams will vote
nay on the motion to recommit
there's
nice
for what purpose does the gentleman from
new jersey seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
miss bonnie watson coleman
pursuant to h res 8 i informed the house
that miss
watson coleman will vote no on the
motion to recommit
and as a member designated by mr albio
series pursuant to hres 8.
i informed the house that mr series will
vote no
on the motion to recommit and mr speaker
as the member
designated by mr donald payne pursuant
to hres 8.
i inform the house that mr payne will
vote no
on the motion to recommit
for what purpose is gentlemen from ohio
seek recognition
mr right honorable honorable speaker as
a member designated
by mr guardino from new york pursuant to
hrs8
i inform the house and mr garbino will
vote
yay on the motion to recommit
for what purpose does the gentleman from
maryland seek recognition
mr speaker as a member destiny by ms
sanfumi of maryland pursuant to h race
informed the house and mrs shampume will
vote no
on the motion to recommit
sisters
now
first voted
uh
so
on this vote the yays are 202
the nays are 216. the motion is not
adopted
the question is on the passage of the
bill those in favor say aye
those opposed say no in the opinion of
the chair of the
nice habit
gentleman from maryland
to section 3s of house resolution 8 the
yes and acer order members will record
their vote by
electronic device
purpose does the gentleman from new
jersey seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
miss bonnie watson coleman pursuant to
hres eight
i informed the house that miss watson
coleman will vote yes
on h.r 1868 as the member designated by
mr alveo
series pursuant to h res 8. i informed
the house that mr series will vote yes
on h.r 1868 and as the member designated
by mr donald payne
pursuant to hres 8 i inform the house
that mr payne
will vote yes on h.r 1868
but does the general from tcc
recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr desjarlais
tennessee pursuant to h res 8
i informed the house that mr desjarlais
will vote nay
on h.r 1868.
thank you
for what purpose does the gentleman from
maryland seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr champumi of maryland pursuant to hrs8
i inform the house and mr infumway will
vote yes on
h.r 1868.
for what purpose does gemma from ohio
seek recognition
uh mr speaker as a member designated by
mr
garberino of new york pursuant to eight
house res
eight resolution number eight inform the
house that mr garbarino will vote
yay on passage of h.r 1868.
86. the gentleman from california seek
recognition
mr speaker is a member designated by mr
schneider pursuant to house resolution
eight
i informed the house that mr schneider
will vote i on h.r
1868 and as the member designated by mr
barrow pursuant to house resolution
eight
i informed the house that mr barrow will
vote i on house resolution 1868.
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from illinois seek recognition
as the member designated by mr rush
pursuant to hbs8 i informed the house
that mr rush will vote yes on h.r 1868
as the member designated by mr moulton
pursuant to hbs8
i inform the house and mr moulton will
vote yes on h.r 1868.
for what purpose does the jet woman from
california seek recognition
and the member designated by mr
desanyang pursuant to h
res eight i informed the house that mr
desanie will vote yes
on h.r 1868.
it's interesting
for what purpose does the gentleman from
rhode island seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by ms
pingree of maine pursuant to house
resolution eight
i inform the house that ms finger will
vote yes on h.r
1868.
what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
as the member designated by mr vicente
gonzalez pursuant to hres eight i
informed the house
that mr vicente gonzalez will vote eye
on h.r 1868
as the member designated by mr carnos
pursuant to hres eight inform the house
that mr carnes will vote i
on h.r 1868.
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from california seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms williams pursuant to hs8 i informed
the house that ms williams will vote yay
on h.r 1868.
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from kansas seek recognition
uh mr speaker as the member designated
by mr allred pursuant to hsa i inform
the house that mr allred will vote yes
on h.r 1868 as the member designated by
mr cleaver pursuant to hs-8i and from
the house and mr cleaver will vote yes
on h.r 1868.
as the member designated by mr kim
pursuant to hrs 89 from the house that
mr kimball vote yes on h.r 1868.
for what purpose does the general woman
from indiana seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
buchanan of indiana pursuant to hres
aide i informed the house that mr
bushon will vote no on h.r 1868.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
new york seek recognition remember
designated by congressman brendan boyle
pursuant to hres-8 to inform the house
that congressman boyle will vote yay
on h.r 1868
for what purpose does the gentleman from
florida seek recognition
thank you mr speaker as the member
designated by mr buchanan of florida
pursuant to house resolution number
eight i inform the house that mr
buchanan will vote yes
on h.r 1868.
for what purpose does german from
virginia seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by ms
moore pursuant to his eight i inform the
house
mrs morrow vote yes on h.r 1868
as the member designated by ms baragon
pursuant to israel's eight
and four that's miss baragon will vote
yes on h.r 1868.
as member designated by mr blumenthaler
pursuant to hrs8
and forming the estimation blooming hour
we'll vote yes on h.r 1868.
as the member destiny mr lowenthal
pursuant to treason eight i informed the
estimates alone with all vote yes
on h.r 1868 as the member designated by
mr liu pursuant to hrs8
and for this mr liu will vote yes on h.r
1868.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker is mimic designated by
congress member of argus pursuant to
house resolution eight
i informed the house that congress
member vargas will vote yes on
h.r 1868
and mr speaker is member designated by
congress member napolitano
pursuant to house resolution eight i
inform the house it's congress member
napolitano
will also vote yes on h.r 1868.
uh
does the gentlewoman from massachusetts
seek recognition
as the member designated by ms bush
pursuant to hres 8 i informed the house
that ms bush will vote
yes on h.r 1868.
as the member designated by ms mang
pursuant to hres 8 i informed the house
that ms ming will vote yes on h.r
1868 and as the member designated by ms
bordeaux pursuant to hres 8 i informed
the house that ms bordeaux will vote yes
on
h.r 1868.
five
very good
for what purpose does the general woman
from virginia seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr murkychin pursuant to her as eight i
inform the house that mr mckeachen
will vote yes on h.r 1868 and as the
member designated by mrs porter pursuant
to
reza i inform the house and ms porter
will vote yes on h.r 1868.
five
purpose does the gentleman from north
carolina seek recognition
as a member designated by mr bishop of
georgia
pursuant to hres 8 i informed the house
that mr bishop will vote yes
he will vote yes on h.r 1868
as a member designated by mr hastings of
florida
restore it to hprs8 i inform the house
if mr hastings
will vote yes he will vote yes on h.r
1868.
okay
property
this corner
for what purpose does the gentleman from
illinois seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr grijalva pursuant to hrs-8 i informed
the house that mr grijalva
will vote yes on h.r 1868.
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from connecticut seek recognition
as the member designated by miss wilson
pursuant to hres 8
i informed the house that miss wilson
will vote yes
on h.r 1868.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
pennsylvania seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
lawson of florida
pursuing the house of resolution eight i
informed the house that mr lawson will
vote yes
on final passage
the gentlewoman from michigan seek
recognition mr speaker
as the member designated by ms axne
pursuant to his eight i inform the house
that ms
axne will vote yes on h.r one eight six
eight as the member designated by ms
slatkin pursuant to hres eight
i informed the house that ms slotkin
will vote yes on
h.r one eight six eight
yes
so
is
so
for what purpose does the gentleman from
pennsylvania seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by
representative kathy mcmorris rogers
pursuant to house res
8. i inform the house that
representative rogers
will vote no on h.r 1868.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
arizona seek recognition
as the member designated by mr patrick
pursuit hdrs eight i inform the house
that mr patrick will vote
yes on h.r 1868.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
massachusetts seek recognition
good morning mr speaker as the member
designated by the honorable mr james
langevin of rhode island and pursuant to
h.r
eight i'd like to inform the house that
mr langevin will vote yes on final
passage of h.r
1868 to prevent across the board direct
spending cuts and for other purposes
thank you
so
tonight
so
oh
so
so
for what purpose does the gentleman from
florida seek recognition
madam speaker as a member designated by
miss wasserman schultz
pursuant to hres eight inform the house
that miss wasserman schultz will vote
yes on h.r 1868.
for what purpose does a gentleman from
connecticut seek recognition
thank you madam speaker madam speaker is
the member designated by mr adam smith
of washington state pursuant to hres
eight
i inform the house that mr smith will
vote yes on h.r
[Music]
1868.
time
this is
so
like
so
uh
so
so
for what purpose does the gentleman from
michigan seek recognition
madam speaker as the member designated
by mr peters of california pursuant to
hrs8
i inform the house that mr peters will
vote yes on
h.r 1868.
so
for what purpose for what purpose
for what purpose is it he's not paying
attention
for what purpose does a gentleman from
florida seek recognition
mr timmins of south carolina pursuant to
hres 8 i informed the house
that mr timmons will vote no on h.r
1868.
so
for what purpose does the gentleman from
indiana seek recognition
as the mess as the member designated by
mr kahali pursuant to h
resolution eight i informed the house
that mr kahele will vote yes
on h.r 1868.
for what purpose does a gentleman from
florida seek recognition
madam speaker is the member designated
by mr gates pursuant to
house res eight i informed the house
that mr gates will vote
nay on h.r 1868.
okay
to change
so
246 and the nays are 175.
the bill is passed and without objection
the motion to reconsider is laid on the
table
good morning
the house will be in order
house will be in order
the chair asks that all members in the
chamber
as well as members and staff throughout
the capital
to rise for a moment of silence in honor
of the victims of the horrific shootings
in georgia this week and in solidarity
with all members of the aapi community
facing discrimination and violence
thank you
pursuant to clause 8 of rule 20
the unfinished business of is the vote
on the motion of the gentleman from new
york mr meeks
to suspend the rules and agree to house
resolution
134 on which the yeas and nays are
ordered
the clerk will report the title house
resolution 134
resolution condemning the military coup
that took place on february 1st 2021
in burma and the burmese military
detention of civilian leaders
calling for the release of all those
detained and for those elected to serve
in parliament to resume their duties and
for other purposes
the question is will the house suspend
the rules and agree to the resolution
members will record their vote by
recorded
device
for what reason does the gentleman from
maryland seek recognition
mr speaker as remembered as anybody
mission fumi of maryland platoon to hres
eight
i informed the house that mr anfumway
will vote yes on hres
134
for what reason does the gentleman from
north carolina to seek recognition
as the member designate mr bishop of
georgia pursuant to hres 8 i informed
the house that mr bishop
will vote yes on hres 134
as a member designated by mr hastings of
florida
pursuant to hres 8 hres 8 i informed the
house that mr hastings will vote
yes on hres 134.
what first does the gentlelady from
indiana seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr buchan of indiana pursuant to hres 8
i
inform the house that mr bushon will
vote yay
on h.r 134
for what purpose does the gentleman from
arizona seek recognition
as the member designated by mr patrick
pursuant hrs8 i inform the house ms
kirkpatrick will vote
yes on hres 134.
for what purpose did the gentleman from
pennsylvania seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
representative kathy mcmorris rogers
pursuant to house whereas eight
i informed the house that representative
rogers will vote
yes on hres 134.
for what purpose does the gentlelady
from california seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
desogne
pursuant to hres eight i'm from the
house of mr
will vote yes on hres 134
for what purpose does the gentleman from
florida seek recognition
mr speaker mr speaker
you hear me mr speaker is the member
designated by mr
timmins of south carolina pursuant to
hres 8 i informed the house that mr
timmins will vote
yes on h res 134
for what purpose does the gentleman from
connecticut seek recognition
thank you mr speaker mr speaker as the
member designated by mr adam smith of
washington state pursuant to hres 8
i informed the house that mr smith will
vote yes on hres 134.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
michigan seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr peters of california pursuant to hres
eight
i informed the house that mr peters will
vote yes on atres 134.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
rhode island seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by
miss pingree of maine pursuant to house
resolution eight i
inform the house that ms pingu will vote
yes on house resolution 134
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr carnes pursuant to hra's eight i
inform the house and mr carnos will vote
i on
h res-134 as the member designated by mr
vicente gonzalez pursuant to hres eight
inform the house the mr vicente gonzalez
will vote i
on hres134
i know for what purpose does the
gentle lady from massachusetts seek
recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms bush pursuant to atres 8
i informed the house that ms bush will
vote yes
on hres 134. as the member designated by
ms
meng pursuant to hres 8 i informed the
house that ms meng will vote yes
on hres 134 and as the member designated
by
ms bordeaux pursuant to hres 8 i
informed the house that ms bordeaux will
vote yes
on hres 134
for what purpose does a gentle lady from
michigan seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms slatkin pursuant to her as eight
i informed the house that ms slacken
will vote yes on hres134
as the member designated by miss axne
pursuant to her as eight
i inform the house that ms axne will
vote yes on hres 134.
for what purpose does a gentleman from
florida seek recognition
mr speaker is a member designated by mr
gates pursuant to house res
8. i informed the house that mr gates
will vote
no on atres 134
for what purpose does the gentleman from
massachusetts seek recognition
is
for what purpose does the gentleman from
indiana seek recognition
as the mes as the member designated by
mr kahele pursuant h
resolution eight i inform the house that
mr kahele will vote yes
on h resolution 134.
what purpose does the gentleman from
florida seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by
miss wasserman schultz pursuant to hres
8
and inform the house that miss wasserman
schultz will vote yes on h
res 134
for what purpose does the gentleman from
ohio seek recognition
thank you mr speaker as a member
designated by mr guardino of new york
pursuant to hres 8 i informed the house
of mr guardino will vote
yay on hres 134
for what purpose does the gentleman from
pennsylvania seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
lawson in florida pursue it the
house of elizabeth a informed the house
that mr lawson will vote
on house resolution 134
for what purpose does the gentleman from
new jersey seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
miss bonnie watson coleman pursuant to
hres 8
i informed the house that miss watson
coleman will vote yes on hres 134
and as the member designated by mr
albio's series pursuant to hres 8
and form the house of mr series will
vote yes on hres 134
and as the member designated by mr
donald payne pursuant to atres 8
i inform the house that mr payne will
vote yes on h
res 134 and finally as the member
designated by miss mikey cheryl
pursuant to age res 8 i informed the
house that ms cheryl
will vote yes on hres 134.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
florida seek recognition
thank you mr speaker as the member
designated by mr buchanan of florida
pursuant to house resolution number
eight i informed the house that mr
buchanan
will vote yes on house resolution 134
thank you
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker as member designated by
congress member vargas pursuant to house
resolution eight
i inform the house that congress member
of argus will vote yes on
hrs 134 and mr speaker as member
designated by congress member napolitano
pursuant to house resolution eight i
informed the house that congress member
napolitano will also vote yes on
hrs 134
for what purpose does the gentleman from
illinois seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr grijalva pursuant to hrs8 i hereby
inform the house that mr
halva will vote yes on a house
resolution 134.
is
this is
mr series
so
so
so
um
for what purpose does the gentleman from
virginia seek recognition
mr speaker from virginia is the member
designated by
mr blumenour of oregon pursuant to his
aid i informed the house mr bloom and i
will vote yes on
atres 134. as the member deserved ms
moore of wisconsin pursuit hr has ada
and foreign will vote yes on nato's 134
as the member destiny ms baragon of
california pursuant to his eight and
four that's ms baragon we'll vote yes on
hrs 134
as a member destitute by dr lowenthal of
california president davis eight nine
four in the house of doctor lowenthal
yes i nature is 134. that's a member
disney by colonel
liu of california pursuant to his aid i
informed the house to colonel louisville
yes on hs134
uh
for what purpose does the gentleman from
new york seek recognition
as a member designated by congressman
brendan boyle pursuant to hres eight
inform the house that congressman boyle
will vote yay on hres
134
is
to me
what purpose does a gentleman from
tennessee seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr desjarlais
of tennessee pursuant to hres eight
i informed the house that mr desjarlais
will vote yay
on h res 134 thank you
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
mr barrow pursuant to house resolution 8
i informed the house that mr bera will
vote eye on house resolution
134 and mr speaker is the member
designated by mr schneider pursuant to
house resolution eight i inform the
house that mr schneider
will vote i on house resolution 134.
is
this is
uh
for what purpose does the gentlelady
from virginia
seek recognition madam speaker as the
member designated by mr mckinson
pursuant to hres8
i inform the house that mr mckitchen
will vote yes on hres
134 and as the member designated by miss
porter pursuant to her as eight
i'm formed the house and miss porter
will vote yes on hres 134
limitations
for what purpose does the gentlelady
from kansas seek recognition
madam speaker is the member designated
by mr allred pursuant to hrs8 i inform
the house that mr allred will vote yes
on hres134
as the member designated by mr cleaver
pursuant to his eight i inform the house
that mr cleaver will vote yes on
hrs 134 as a member designated by mr kim
pursuant to his aid i inform the house
that mr kim will vote yes on hres 134
what's your pleasure
mr
for what purpose does the gentlelady
from california seek recognition
madam speaker as the member designated
by ms williams pursuant to hs8 i inform
the house that ms williams will vote yes
on hres 134
is
okay
this
okay
have all members voted to change
foreign
on this vote the yeas are 398 the nays
are 14
and one is present two-thirds being in
the affirmative the rules are suspended
the resolution is agreed to
and without objection the motion to
reconsider is laid on the table
for what purpose does the gentleman from
nevada seek recognition
madam speaker i ask unanimous consent to
remove congressman clay higgins
from h.r 1346 the hospitality
and commerce jobs recovery act without
objection so ordered
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from california seek recognition
madam speaker i send to the desk a
resolution and ask unanimous consent
for its immediate consideration in the
house the clerk will report the title of
the resolution
house resolution 257 resolution
requiring each member
officer and employee of the house of
representatives to complete a program of
training and workplace rights and
responsibilities
each session of each congress and for
other purposes
is there objection to the consideration
of the resolution
without objection the resolution is
agreed to and the motion to reconsider
is laid on the table
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
madam speaker i ask unanimous consent to
take from the speaker's table the bill
h.r 1276 would the senate amendment
thereto
and concur in the senate amendment
the clerk will report the title of the
bill and the senate amendment
h.r 1276 an act to authorize the
secretary of veterans affairs to furnish
cobit 19 vaccines
to certain individuals and for other
purposes
dismissed with the reading madam speaker
without objection the reading is dissent
dispensed with is there objection to the
request of the gentleman from california
without objection the senate amendment
is agreed to and the motion to
reconsider is laid on the table
the chair will now entertain requests
for one-minute speeches
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from texas seek recognition
i asked to address the house and revise
and extend my remarks
for one minute without objection the
gentlewoman is recognized for one minute
i want to take this brief moment to
salute latrice
powell
okay i'm sorry are you
and the gentlewoman for is is recognized
for one minute
all right thank you i'd like to take
this moment to recognize uh latrice
powell
uh we are humbled by her service
i wear on my jacket lady freedom
i would argue that latrice powell is our
sojourner truth
because she's a pioneer and has made an
enormous difference
in this house that is a people's house
she truly is
a representative of the people with that
in mind i thank her
so very much for all that she's done and
i must take this separate moment
again as she knows to honor those who
died in atlanta
to honor them for the vowel way in which
they lost their life
to say that those women asian american
women
really were the victims of hate crimes
why
because women gender can be a hate crime
and i'd only say to my colleague a
friend of mine
yes from texas in the midst of pain
to talk about a rope and an oak tree
as a tradition of texas lynching
is absurd unacceptable and i denounce
and i apologize for any hurt that was
given to the asian american community
i asked my colleague to apologize and i
asked
us to join together against hate crimes
thank you the gentlewoman's time is up
for what purpose does a gentle man from
ohio seek recognition
madam speaker i seek unanimous consent
to address the house for one minute and
to revise and extend my remarks
without a rejection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute
thank you madam speaker i rise today in
memory of mitch stone he was a
university of cincinnati
football superfan and an inspirational
young man who passed away
years after his battle with brain cancer
in 2009 at age 11 mitch stone was
diagnosed with a malignant brain tumor
the cincinnati bearcats football team
took mitch in as one of their own
and saw him through his treatments mitch
found strength and support through the
uc bearcats football team
and they found strength in him mitch
went on to attend the university of
cincinnati
where he earned a bachelor's degree in
2020
he was a colossal business scholar an
honors program
at the carl h lindner college of
business mitch used his experience to
start his own foundation called mitch's
mission
which helped children overcome their own
health challenges
mitch's death is a tragedy that we
continue to mourn
but his life is a testimony to the good
in this world
his legacy and the positive effects of
his works will live on
rest in peach miss and i yield back
gentleman yells back what purpose does
the gentlewoman from california seek
recognition
madam speaker i ask unanimous consent to
address the house for one minute
without rejection the gentlewoman is
recognized for one minute
madam speaker before covent 19 more than
40 percent of san diego kids were
already living in families experiencing
poverty
childhood poverty was a problem before
covent 19.
and we know it's only worsened through
this pandemic
america's kids deserve better that's why
i was so proud to fight for them through
the american rescue plan and so proud to
see the bill signed into law last week
the american rescue plan makes historic
investments to increase the child tax
credit
and support our child care
infrastructure to help working families
and our care workers these investments
will be
transformational cutting childhood
poverty in half
and lifting a heavy burden off the
shoulders of so many parents
today i celebrate this progress and
today i commit myself to working
to support the 5 million american
children who will still experience
poverty let's make the child tax credit
increases permanent
let's revitalize our child care
infrastructure and let's do right by
america's kids
i yield back for what purpose does the
gentleman from nebraska seek
recognition madam speaker i ask
unanimous consent to address the house
for one minute and revise and extend my
remarks
without objection your gentleman is
recognized for one minute
thank you madam speaker my district in
nebraska is home to
many native american tribes including
the winnebago in the northeast corner of
the state
and it's nestled madam speaker along the
missouri river bottoms
at the beginning of the great plains and
a beautiful setting of
rolling hills this land this tribal land
has been an
integral part of nebraska's history and
culture
but several decades ago land belonging
to the winnebago was appropriated by the
army corps of engineers for development
in 1976 a federal court found that the
united states and the corps
lacked the authority to take this land
through imminent domain
it's time to make this right so the
winnebago land transfer act is an
important bill
to return to the winnebago this piece of
land
hunters will be able to continue to
enjoy this prime spot along the missouri
river through the winnebago tribe
wildlife and parks program and so i'm
appreciative of the effort the
bipartisan effort here
of our colleagues darren soto of florida
cerise davis of kansas as well as randy
feinster of iowa
to once again make this right thank you
madam speaker
for what purpose does a gentle woman
from
minnesota seek recognition madam speaker
i ask unanimous consent to address the
house for one minute and revise and
extend my remarks
without objection the gentlewoman is
recognized for one minute
madam speaker last weekend i visited
women-owned businesses in shakopee
and i had the pleasure of meeting elise
steger
who owns chakra yoga and fitness
throughout this past year hallease has
done everything she can to comply with
coveted restrictions
while continuing to pay her employees
and keep her business open
with the help of the paycheck protection
program loans
she has also turned to creative
solutions like virtual classes
but she's been able to keep her business
going the paycheck protection program
has served as a lifeline to small
businesses
like elise's but in less than two weeks
it's due to expire
this week we passed legislation in the
house on a bipartisan basis
to extend this critical program through
may 31st
we must ensure that that extension
becomes law
thank you and i yield back thank you
for what purpose does the gentleman
gentle woman from iowa
uh seek recognition thank you madam
speaker i request unanimous consent to
address the house for one minute and to
revise and extend my remarks
without objections the gentlewoman is
recognized for one minute
thank you madam speaker i rise today to
recognize a local hero
in my hometown of ottumwa iowa this
coming wednesday march 24th
mary margaret butler of ottumwa will be
recognized as a 2021
hero of the heartland by the american
red cross mary margaret is being
recognized for founding
whatsoever you do inc a non-profit that
has worked tirelessly on creating
shelters for the homeless in
southeastern iowa for years now
whatsoever you do
has helped hundreds with basic needs
such as food clothing and housing
across the country the red cross works
every day through programs and services
related to disaster relief the military
health and safety
and helping the homeless the hero of the
heartland awards
recognizes outstanding individuals who
demonstrate courage compassion
selflessness and work to better and help
their neighbors and communities
i am proud to not only represent mary
margaret butler in congress but
am proud to call her a neighbor thank
you mary margaret for making ottumwa a
better place to live
additionally i'd like to wish a happy
birthday to two other amazing women of
integrity selflessness and compassion
and courage my chief of staff tracy
gibler and my daughter taylor miller
migs
madam speaker i yield back my time
for what purpose does a gentleman from
texas seek recognition madam speaker i
desire to
address the house for one minute to
revise and extend my remarks
without objection the gentleman from
texas is recognized
one minute thank you madam speaker madam
speaker when you're a son
of the segregated south when you've
heard your mother called
girl and your father called boy
when you've had to go to the back door
when you've had the plan to burn across
on your property you know hate when you
see it
you know what a hate crime is when it
takes place
what happened in georgia was hate
personified
it was a hate crime i will march with
the people who will be
opposed to this i will stand with them
we cannot
allow this kind of injustice to go
unchallenged
it is better to stand alone than not
stand at all this is a hate crime and we
must
we must seek justice for those victims
and we must demand
that these persons who are calling these
viruses by names associated with people
that they ought to stop and we ought to
demand it i do so
i demand that they stop i yield back
for what purpose does a gentleman from
north carolina seek recognition
madam speaker i rise and you ask of
unanimous consent to address the house
for one minute and to revise and extend
my remarks
without objection the gentleman from is
recognized for one minute
madam speaker there is nothing an
american will not do to defend his
country
i rise today in defense of my homeland i
am angry
not just for the destruction of an
american of american values perpetrated
by those on the left
but i am angry because my colleagues
simply do not seem to care
they do not care that our border is
non-existent that 6
000 criminals cross into our country
daily they do not care that 64 percent
of federal
arrests are of illegal immigrants and
they do not care that america's welfare
and infrastructure system
simply cannot handle this influx of
criminal immigrants
they do not care because to them power
is all that matters i have a message to
the power hungry and the partisan
power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely
it is in the nature of americans to be
kind it is in our nature to be gentle
and loving but know this when it comes
to the matter of protecting our friends
our family and our heartland do not
trifle with this representative
democracy
for we the people will not stop we will
never back down
we will give our everything to protect
those dear to us gentlemen
this is our republic finish the wall
does the gentleman from wisconsin
seek recognition i'd like to speak for
one minute
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute
we are now being sent home for three
weeks i don't know that's coincidence or
not that we're being sent home and we
have such a
problem at our border and we just got
done voting on a few immigration bills
i'm particularly concerned we all of us
congressmen should have a to-do list
over the next three weeks
i want to give the press corps a to-do
list right now our border patrol
is under a gag order in which they
cannot educate the press
or congressmen as to what is really
going on this at a time in which you
have
almost three times as many people trying
to get across the border
as this at then as this time last year
and we have huge numbers of
unaccompanied minors down there
the press should be outraged at this gag
order i have been at the border four
times so far
over the last couple years and it's
always very illuminating what the border
patrol
can say to us now like we're in some
totalitarian state
they are not allowed to speak to us i
don't care whether you care about the
government benefits the unaccompanied
minors the drug trafficking the human
trafficking
the money the drug cartels are making on
the illegal immigration
we should want to know and we can't know
unless the board of gentlemen's time has
expired
please wake up sleeping press corps
thank you
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition to address
the house for one minute and revise and
extend my remarks
without rejection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute
last year portland oregon cut 16 million
dollars from their police budget
this has led to a 20-fold increase
unfortunately in deadly shootings
mayor wheeler has been forced to reverse
course now and ask for more funding for
police
similar to this the by demonstration has
been having to reverse course
due to the crisis on the border now many
are getting hung up on using the word
crisis
so is fema now involved and they deal
with disasters
hence the biden border disaster
less than two months in the border is
worse this man than in two decades
and now biden has forced to has been
forced to reverse course and ask mexico
to help control the flow of migrants
once again
after previously dismantling the remain
in mexico policy
also on his first day in the
administration they issued a
proclamation to halt all border
construction
despite congress funding it and
demanding it to be built
now just yesterday the administration
has said it was moving forward with
border construction
well border wall good
as they're learning in portland seattle
minneapolis the byte administration is
learning
law and order is also required on our
border or you get
disaster i yield back thank you
are there any further requests for
one-minute speeches
before the house of communications
the honorable the speaker house of
representatives madam i write to
respectfully
tender my resignation as a member of the
joint economic committee
effective immediately it has been an
honor to serve in this capacity
signed sincerely darren lahood
without objection the chair recognizes
they
announces the speaker's appointment
pursuant to 15 usc
10224 a and the order of the house of
january 4th 2021 of the following member
on the part of the house to the joint
economic committee
mr arrington of texas to rank after miss
herrera butler of washington
the chair announces the speaker's
appointment for surrender section 4e of
the house resolution 8 117th congress in
the order
of the house of january 4th 2021 of the
following member to the select committee
on the modernization of congress
mr joyce of ohio to rank after mr lada
of ohio
the speakers of primo pursuant to
section 4 f of house resolution 8 117th
congress and
the order of the house of january 4th
2021 of the following member to the
select committee
subcommittee on the coronavirus crisis
mrs miller meeks of iowa
under the speakers announced policy of
january 4th 2021 the gentleman from
south carolina
mr clyburn is recognized for 60 minutes
as the designee of the majority leader
madam speaker thank you very much for
recognizing me i asked your nana's
consent
that all members have up to five
legislative days to revise and extend
their remarks
and submit extraneous materials on the
subject
without a special order today without
objection
madam speaker last march as a tragic
failure of the trump administration's
response to the coronavirus
pandemic was becoming very apparent
the house democratic caucus held a
conference call
to discuss the crisis recalling the
lessons of history
like the aftermath of world war one
spanish flu the great depression
and world war ii that is usually
the least of these among us that are the
hardest hit
during these crises and the last to
recover
after these crises are over
if they are able to recover at
all
i expressed at that time
to the caucus that the legislation
before us
offered a tremendous opportunity
to restructure things in our vision
i've referring then
as i often do to the vision
expressed in our pledge of allegiance to
our nation's flag
of liberty and justice
for all shortly after
the media reported these comments
senator mcconnell the majority leader of
the senate
derided them on the senate floor
referring to me by a position he
declared
and i quote him here this is not
a political opportunity it is
a national emergency
i wholeheartedly agree with the now
minority leader of the senate
that the coronavirus pandemic was
and remains a national emergency
but because the previous administration
and senate republicans
failed to address it with the
appropriate urgency
and a vision of liberty and justice for
all
the american people through the
political process
last november entrusted democrats
to an opportunity to build back with a
better
and more equitable for the future
of our great country
the american rescue plan has begun that
process
and it is rejoined widespread bipartisan
support
across the entire spectrum of the
country
and it did not get a single
republican vote in the house
or the senate because of the use of the
budget
process commonly called reconciliation
republicans were not able to block the
filibuster
by filibuster the american rescue plan
and that is proven to be
a good thing but the senate minority
leader and several of his colleagues
seem to be held bent on using archaic
senate procedures
to allow the minority in the senate
to block any legislation designed
to protect the voting and civil rights
of our country's minority citizens
as we continue our pursuit toward
the fulfillment of liberty
and justice for all
we have been here before
during the 1940s and 50s
the senate filibuster was used to kill
civil rights
legislation and protect
jim crow laws today
senate republican leaders are employing
the same
tactics to obstruct voting rights
and civil rights legislation
their efforts are designed to gain
power for their party by suppressing
political participation by minorities
the minority leader has threatened
that if senate democrats modify
the filibuster rules to do to him
as he did to president obama
he will resort to scotched
earth tactics
this threat of scotch earth
tactics by the senate minority leader
in defiance of the american democracy is
reminiscent
of mississippi burning which was
highlighted
by the lynching of three civil rights
workers
who were simply registering
black voters in mississippi in june
1964.
they were murdered by the kkk
with the cooperation of law enforcement
officials
to keep them from assisting minority
citizens
who simply wanted to vote
it was 44 days before their bodies were
located
and four decades before anyone
faced legal consequences for their
deaths
today republicans are using the big lie
about the 2020 elections as
a pretext to advance a litany of
minority
voting suppression laws they know
that our vision of liberty and justice
for all
enjoys majority support among voters
so they seek to suppress enough votes
so that their oppressive policies
and bankrupt ideas can prevail
the minority leader wants to allow a
minority
of his minority to block misses
that will prevent a return to bygone
days
to confront this threat
the senate must eliminate the 60-vote
threshold
to end the filibuster on voting rights
and civil rights legislation
just as mississippi burning was met
with the civil rights act and voting
rights act
the threat of scorched earth must be met
before the people act and the john r
lewis voted rights act
i didn't march in the streets and spent
nights in jail
as a young man to find myself
fighting the same battles
generations later but it appears
the minority leader and his republican
colleagues
are preparing to retread old ground
and i am prepared to stand
my ground
to the minority leader
and his colleagues i say
this is not a political opportunity
this is a national emergency
since this country's inception
equal rights for people of color have
been restricted
by those in power who seek to hold on to
power
by using their power to deny
the greatness of this country to those
who do not look like them
extending debate on legislative issues
is one thing but when it comes to rights
rooted in the constitution the
filibuster
has no place
and with that madam speaker i'll give
you back the battle for my time
under the speaker's announced policy of
january 4th 2021 the gentleman from
arizona mr schreiker is recognized for
60 minutes as the designee of the
minority leader
thank you madam speaker um going to do a
couple things right now one of the first
ones
is a little conversation um about
someone we lost in
my community that actually was a friend
a neighbor had impact
in ways that's hard to describe
and i desperately wish the members of
this body
could have spent time with him and and
his wife
um reverend dr
professor c.t wright what was so unique
about him
is he was a big man he had a voice that
carried and you would actually
have conversations with him and realize
just how incredibly brilliant he was he
was born in georgia
he struggled and worked his way up he
ended up with a phd in
history from boston college
he became a civil rights leader and yet
when you would talk to
him about that reverend wright
dr wright actually often wouldn't refer
to himself
as a civil rights leader he would say i
want to lead for humanity
he loved people it was a different
view he actually took his struggles and
his success
and his academic prowess
and said we're going to make people's
lives
better why would you dare focus on the
color of their skin
i remember one of the most interesting
conversations i had with him where he
and i were in the back of the room
and talked and he actually saw many of
actually almost an example of what we
just saw on the floor the discussions
of politics and race and saying david
it's class it's opportunity
that that that divides us it's not our
color
it's our opportunity dr wright
was just a powerful brilliant man
and you see his wife there mary they
were married in 1974.
mary was the epitome of love
i mean how many of us in our lives have
that one person where
your little girl i'm blessed to have a
five-year-old but even when she was
younger
she would see mary mary would sort of
scream and the two of them would run
over and hug each other
just the epitome of love
and that they made them incredibly
powerful
as you felt good by just
knowing dr wright and mary wright
in your community the other thing that
also made him unique
he was a passionate conservative he was
a republican
elector he was the chairman of our
clemency board
he was on my community school board
he was brilliant he cared about humanity
he he ran charities and foundations
to help all people to help people in the
continent of africa
but even people all through our
community
and he was a powerful force for good
because he was good because he was
passionate
because he was caring and we've lost
both
mary and dr wright last year
i'm going to put in a much more detailed
because his
his cv his history goes on page after
page and we'll put that in the
congressional record
but it's individuals like this that
bring us together
but also make us better and it breaks my
heart that
more will not actually get to spend time
with him because
both he and mary after a couple minutes
with him
you felt different and and the last
thing i will say
he loved to give the opening prayer at
republican meetings
and what was always so fascinating is
you'd watch the room
and the room ends up standing up
clapping and i was waiting for an altar
call
now you know i'm catholic so i'm not
used to the concept of an altar call
but watching someone be able to have
such energy
and vigor and enthusiasm and love for
people and love for
believing that conservatism is actually
how you free people
he made an impact and made an impact on
my life my family's life
my community my state and i believe he
made an impact on this country
madam speaker i wanted to do a handful
of other things
because with the craziness of our
schedule
we haven't had a chance to sort of walk
through a lot of policy thoughts
but there's one that's been bugging me
so i have the hour so
i was going to share something that's
just been in my craw for a while
do we all remember a few years ago
ancient history in politics we seem to
have the
um shall we say the attention span of a
gnat
one of the pop culture debates we on the
right and the left were having
was something called net neutrality the
democrats were all into net neutrality
even though
i will debate most of this body had no
idea
what actual net neutrality was and i
want to sort of
argue that thank heaven
thank the internet gods that the
democrats net neutrality push
only lasted one year our thing
you